bienvenido de nuevo a "Entendiendo la información y la computación cuántica", mi nombre es John Watrous y soy el director técnico de educación en IBM Quantum
esta es la lección 13 de la serie y es la primera lección de la cuarta y última unidad, que trata sobre el error cuántico
la corrección de errores cuánticos tiene el potencial de permitir soluciones eficientes a tareas computacionales para las cuales
no se conocen algoritmos clásicos eficientes y posiblemente no existen; sin embargo, hay desafíos muy significativos que
habrá que superar si queremos implementar el tipo de computaciones cuánticas a gran escala que esperamos que algún día sean
posibles; el núcleo del asunto es que la información cuántica es extremadamente frágil: puedes arruinarla literalmente con solo
observarla, y por eso, para funcionar correctamente, los ordenadores cuánticos necesitan aislar la información cuántica que
almacenan del entorno que los rodea en un grado extremo; pero al mismo tiempo, el propio ordenador cuántico debe darnos un
control muy preciso sobre esta información cuántica, y eso incluye una inicialización correcta, operaciones
unitarias precisas y fiables, y por supuesto la capacidad de realizar mediciones para poder obtener los resultados de la
computación; hay claramente cierta tensión entre estos requisitos, y en los primeros tiempos de la computación cuántica, algunos pensaban que la fragilidad
de la información cuántica y su susceptibilidad tanto a las imprecisiones como al ruido ambiental harían que
la computación cuántica fuera imposible; hoy en día hay pocas dudas de que construir un ordenador cuántico preciso y fiable a
gran escala es un desafío monumental, pero tenemos una herramienta clave para ayudarnos en este empeño que lleva a la mayoría
de las personas que conocen el campo a ser optimistas sobre que la computación cuántica a gran escala se convierta algún día en una realidad, y esa herramienta es la corrección de errores cuánticos
en las próximas cuatro lecciones hablaremos sobre la corrección de errores cuánticos con un enfoque en los
fundamentos; en esta lección daremos un primer vistazo a la corrección de errores cuánticos, incluyendo uno de los primeros
códigos correctores de errores cuánticos descubiertos: el código Shore de 9 qubits, y también discutiremos otro concepto fundamental en la corrección de errores cuánticos
conocido como la discretización de errores; en las lecciones posteriores de la unidad veremos construcciones de códigos correctores de errores cuánticos más sofisticadas y en última instancia mejores
también discutiremos el problema de la computación cuántica sobre información cuántica codificada usando
componentes computacionales que no son perfectos y son propensos a errores; aquí hay un breve resumen de la
lección: empezaremos discutiendo los códigos de repetición clásicos, que son quizás el tipo más simple y básico
de código corrector de errores clásico; los códigos de repetición clásicos no son códigos particularmente buenos según los estándares clásicos
de la teoría de la codificación, al menos por sí solos, pero eso está bien; aquí buscamos la simplicidad, y en particular
veremos el código corrector de errores clásico más simple que puedas imaginar, que luego usaremos como base para un ejemplo sencillo
de un código corrector de errores cuántico; ese ejemplo es el código Shore de 9 qubits, que discutiremos en detalle
incluyendo una descripción del código en sí, así como los procedimientos para codificar qubits usando este código, detectar errores en qubits codificados y
corregir esos errores; en la tercera parte de la lección discutiremos la discretización de errores, que nos permite pensar en errores arbitrarios sobre
qubits, que en principio forman un continuo de posibilidades, en términos discretos, reduciendo esencialmente los errores a los
llamados bit flips y phase flips; antes de entrar en los detalles técnicos de la corrección de errores cuánticos, vale
la pena tomarse un momento para reflexionar sobre la necesidad de la corrección de errores cuánticos, así como de la corrección de errores clásicos
como mencioné al inicio de la lección, los ordenadores cuánticos son muy susceptibles a los errores debido a
la fragilidad de la información cuántica; en particular, las interacciones no deseadas con el entorno, o en
otras palabras, el resto del mundo, pueden perturbar la información cuántica; estas interacciones no deseadas pueden causar decoherencia, donde la información
esencialmente se filtra al entorno, haciendo que la información almacenada por el ordenador cuántico se comporte cada vez más
de forma clásica; también es de vital importancia que reconozcamos que las operaciones cuánticas solo pueden realizarse con una precisión limitada
por ejemplo, puede que queramos realizar un gate cuántico concreto sobre un qubit, pero como los dispositivos físicos nunca son
perfectos, lo que realmente implementamos podría ser solo una aproximación a ese gate; eso puede no ser gran problema para un
solo gate, pero si nuestra intención es realizar miles o millones de gates cuánticos, estas pequeñas imprecisiones
comenzarán a acumularse y cuando la computación termine podríamos terminar con un estado muy diferente al que
esperábamos; así que esta es una fuente de errores bastante diferente, pero desde luego una que no podemos
ignorar; la gente lleva cerca de un siglo estudiando los códigos correctores de errores clásicos, y estos códigos tienen muchas aplicaciones, incluyendo en
la transmisión y el almacenamiento de información; pero como los componentes de la computación clásica son tan fiables, en realidad no
necesitamos la corrección de errores para construir ordenadores clásicos; ahora bien, puede que la corrección de errores tampoco sea necesaria
para construir ordenadores cuánticos a gran escala y fiables; por ejemplo, la idea principal detrás de la computación cuántica topológica
es que podría ser posible construir sistemas cuánticos robustos que estén inherentemente protegidos contra el ruido debido
a las propiedades topológicas de los sistemas; pero no sabemos si esto será posible, y se cree ampliamente que
la corrección de errores probablemente será esencial de una forma u otra para la computación cuántica a gran escala; ahora discutiremos los códigos de
repetición clásicos, que forman la base de nuestro primer código corrector de errores cuántico: el código Shore de 9 qubits, que
veremos en breve; los códigos de repetición son ejemplos extremadamente básicos de códigos correctores de errores
la idea es que podemos proteger bits contra errores simplemente repitiendo cada bit un número de veces; en particular, veamos
el código de repetición de tres bits: aquí codificamos un bit en tres simplemente repitiendo el bit tres veces, así que
el cero se codifica como 000 y el uno se codifica como 111; por supuesto, si nada sale mal,
podemos distinguir fácilmente las dos posibilidades; pero si hubo un error y uno de los bits cambió, digamos
que un cero cambia a uno o un uno cambia a cero, todavía podemos averiguar cuál era el bit original
viendo cuál de los dos valores binarios aparece dos veces; equivalentemente, podemos decodificar calculando el valor mayoritario
o en otras palabras el valor binario que aparece con más frecuencia, y no es difícil ver que
si tenemos como máximo un error de bit flip, la decodificación será correcta; por supuesto, si dos bits cambian o si
los tres bits cambian, no funcionará y obtendremos el valor incorrecto al decodificar, y esa es una propiedad general
que posee todo código corrector de errores: puede que puedas corregir algunos errores, pero nunca podrás corregir todos los errores; y en última instancia se trata de
reducir la probabilidad de un error en lugar de garantizar la corrección, lo que en general no es
posible; como ejemplo de una situación en la que podemos reducir la probabilidad de cometer un error, supongamos que nuestro
objetivo es comunicar un solo bit a un receptor hipotético, y para ello podemos transmitir bits a través de un
canal simétrico binario, que invierte cada bit enviado a través de él de forma independiente con cierta probabilidad
P; así, con probabilidad 1 menos P, el receptor recibirá el bit que pretendíamos enviar, pero con probabilidad P
el bit se invierte y el receptor obtiene el valor opuesto al que enviamos; así que si no usamos el código de repetición
y en cambio simplemente enviamos el bit que tenemos en mente a través del canal, el receptor obtendrá el bit incorrecto con
probabilidad p. Por otro lado, si primero codificamos el bit que queremos enviar usando el código de repetición de tres bits y
luego enviamos cada uno de los tres bits de la codificación a través del canal, entonces cada uno de ellos se invierte con probabilidad P, así que
las probabilidades de una inversión de bit son ahora mayores porque ahora hay tres bits que podrían invertirse en lugar de uno.
Pero si a lo sumo uno de los bits se invierte, el receptor podrá decodificar correctamente, así que solo obtendremos un error después de
decodificar si dos o más de los bits se invierten durante la transmisión, y no es tan difícil calcular que esto ocurre con
probabilidad 3 * P ^2 - 2 * P cúbico, para valores de P menores que 1/12.
Esto lleva a una disminución en la probabilidad de que el receptor termine con el bit incorrecto. Aún habrá posibilidad de error en este caso, pero el
código reduce la probabilidad de que esto ocurra, y si quisieras reducir aún más esa posibilidad, podrías hacerlo usando un
código diferente, incluyendo, entre otras opciones, la posibilidad de usar un código de repetición donde el bit codificado se repite
más de tres veces. Para valores de P mayores que 1/12, por cierto, el código en realidad
empeora las cosas en el sentido de que aumenta la probabilidad de que el receptor reciba el bit incorrecto, así que ciertamente no usaríamos este código en esa
situación. El código de repetición de tres bits es un código clásico de corrección de errores, pero también podemos considerar qué pasa si
intentamos usarlo para proteger qubits contra errores. No es un código cuántico de corrección de errores muy bueno, como veremos; sí
puede corregir algunos errores, pero hace que otros sean más probables. Sin embargo, es el primer paso hacia el código de Shor.
Así que veamos cómo funciona para qubits. Primero, para ser claros, cuando hablamos del código de repetición de 3 bits aplicado
a qubits, lo que tenemos en mente es una codificación de un qubit como la que se muestra en pantalla, donde Alpha 0 más beta 1 se
codifica como Alpha 000 más beta 111; o en otras palabras, el estado de la base estándar
se repite tres veces. Nótese en particular que esto no es lo mismo que repetir el estado cuántico tres veces, como cuando un
estado cuántico s se codifica como s tensorial s tensorial s, lo cual no es una codificación que podríamos
implementar para un estado cuántico desconocido s por el teorema de no clonación. La codificación de la que estamos hablando,
por otro lado, se implementa fácilmente. Aquí hay un circuit cuántico muy simple que lo hace usando dos qubits de espacio de trabajo inicializados y dos
gate de NOT controladas. Ahora supongamos que ocurre un error después de que se ha realizado la codificación,
y en particular supongamos que una operación Pauli X, o en otras palabras una inversión de bit, ocurre en uno de
los qubits; y en esta figura es el qubit del medio. Por supuesto, este no es el único tipo de error que podría ocurrir, y puede que
objetés a la idea de que un error tome la forma de esta operación unitaria perfecta, pero volveremos a esto más adelante en la lección. Por ahora podemos
simplemente verlo como un ejemplo. Aquí está el estado resultante: es igual a la codificación original excepto
que el bit del medio dentro de cada ket ha sido invertido. Obviamente podemos ver esto a partir de las expresiones matemáticas del estado.
Pero supongamos que solo tuviéramos los tres qubits y que sospecháramos que podría haber ocurrido una inversión de bit, pero no supiéramos en qué qubit.
Una forma de averiguar si ocurrió una inversión de bit sería realizar una medición en la base estándar y examinar el resultado. En este caso veríamos
0 1 0 o 1 1 0 con probabilidades que dependen de Alpha y beta, y en cualquier caso nuestra conclusión
sería que el bit del medio se invirtió. Pero desafortunadamente eso arruina el estado cuántico original, y este estado
podría ser muy valioso para nosotros. Al fin y al cabo, el objetivo es proteger este estado cuántico, así que esta no es una buena
opción. Lo que podemos hacer en cambio es usar el circuit cuántico que se muestra aquí en pantalla, donde introducimos el estado codificado
en los tres qubits superiores. Básicamente, lo que hace el circuit es calcular la paridad de los estados de la base estándar
para los dos qubits superiores, así como para los dos qubits inferiores de la codificación, y esto revelará la
ubicación de la inversión de bit. En particular, en este caso obtendremos el resultado uno para ambas verificaciones de paridad, y a partir de
esa información podemos concluir que es el bit del medio el que es diferente de los otros dos, así que evidentemente es el que
se invirtió. Y lo crucial es que esto no provoca el colapso del estado, así que ahora tenemos la oportunidad de intentar corregir este bit
invertido para que eventualmente podamos tal vez decodificar y recuperar nuestro estado original. Volveremos a la corrección
en un momento, pero primero consideremos brevemente las otras posibilidades para un error de inversión de bit. Si en cambio el error de inversión de bit
ocurrió en el qubit inferior o izquierdo, entonces obtendríamos el resultado uno cero leyendo de abajo hacia arriba, y de nuevo
el estado no cambiaría. Y si la inversión de bit le ocurrió al qubit superior, entonces la salida sería
0 1 y, una vez más, el estado no cambia. Por cierto, si no hubo
ninguna inversión de bit en absoluto, entonces el resultado de la medición es 0 0, y una vez más el estado sale sin cambios.
Entonces resumamos todo esto en forma de tabla, donde enumeramos cada uno de los posibles estados que obtenemos con a lo sumo una inversión de bit, la medición
de resultados a los que nos referimos como el síndrome en el contexto de la corrección de errores, y la corrección que necesitamos hacer para recuperar la
codificación original. Si no hubo error, el síndrome es 0 0 y no hay nada que hacer para corregir el
estado. Si el qubit inferior o el más a la izquierda experimentó una inversión de bit, el síndrome es 1 0 y la corrección apropiada
es aplicar un gate X al qubit inferior o más a la izquierda. Los otros dos casos son
similares. Así que si aplicamos la corrección apropiada según el síndrome, estaremos seguros de recuperar la
codificación original en los cuatro casos. Una vez más, solo estamos considerando la posibilidad de que a lo sumo una inversión de
bit haya ocurrido. Esto no funcionaría correctamente si se invirtieran dos o tres bits, y tampoco hemos considerado la
posibilidad de otros errores. Ahora consideremos un tipo diferente de error. En el entorno cuántico, las inversiones de
bit no son los únicos errores de los que tenemos que preocuparnos. Por ejemplo, también tenemos que preocuparnos por las inversiones de
fase, o simplemente inversiones de fase, que están descritas por gate Z, o equivalentemente operaciones Pauli Z.
Desafortunadamente, el código de repetición de tres bits falla completamente al detectar inversiones de fase. Por ejemplo, supongamos que
codificamos un qubit usando el código de repetición de 3 bits como antes, y ocurre un error de inversión de fase en el
qubit del medio. Obtendremos el estado que se muestra en pantalla, que es exactamente la codificación que habríamos obtenido si una
inversión de fase hubiera ocurrido en el qubit original antes de codificarlo. Así que si realizamos el mismo
circuit que antes para intentar detectar un error, obtendríamos el síndrome 0 0, que erróneamente sugiere que no ocurrieron errores.
Así que el código de repetición de 3 bits funciona para a lo sumo una inversión de bit, pero falla al detectar inversiones de fase. De hecho,
en cierto sentido empeora las cosas, porque ahora tenemos tres veces más qubits que podrían experimentar inversiones de
fase. Hemos observado que el código de repetición de tres bits es completamente insensible a las inversiones de fase, así que no parece
ser muy útil para lidiar con este tipo de error. Pero de hecho podemos modificar el código de repetición de tres bits para que
sí detecte inversiones de fase, y ahora explicaré cómo se puede hacer esto. Aquí está el circuit original para
codificar un qubit usando el código de repetición de 3 bits, y la forma en que lo modificaremos es muy simple: solo aplicamos un
gate Hadamard a cada qubit de la codificación. Un gate Hadamard transforma un estado cero en un estado más y un estado
uno en un estado menos, así que el efecto neto es que obtenemos el estado que se muestra en pantalla, donde el ket
Plus+ plus y Cat minus- minus son notación abreviada para el tensor de tres estados plus o tres estados minus
Un error de inversión de fase, o dicho de otro modo, un gate Z transforma los estados plus en estados minus y los estados minus en
estados plus, así que esta codificación será útil para detectar y corregir errores de inversión de fase, y para hacerlo podemos
modificar el circuit de detección de errores anterior de la siguiente manera: aquí está el circuit anterior y lo que haremos es
simplemente colocar gates Hadamard tanto al principio como al final, tal como se muestra en la pantalla
La idea es muy simple: los primeros tres gates Hadamard transforman los estados plus y minus de vuelta a los estados cero y uno,
se realizan las mismas comprobaciones de paridad que antes, y luego la segunda capa de gates Hadamard nos devuelve a nuestra
codificación. Otra forma de pensar en esto es que básicamente estamos transformando los errores de inversión de fase en errores de inversión de bit conjugando por operaciones Hadamard
Podemos, por cierto, simplificar el circuit un poco: este circuit de aquí es completamente equivalente
y puedes comprobarlo tú mismo si te apetece. Así que si introducimos nuestro qubit codificado en este circuit, suponiendo
que no hayan ocurrido errores de inversión de fase, obtenemos el síndrome 0 0, lo que indica que no hubo inversiones de fase
Y si tenemos un error de inversión de fase en el qubit superior, por ejemplo, los plus y minus del extremo derecho se invierten
y eso produce un síndrome de error diferente, 01 en este caso, que identifica la ubicación de la inversión de fase igual que
lo teníamos para la inversión de bit, y podemos corregirlo aplicando un gate Z al qubit superior, y la situación
es similar para errores de inversión de fase en cualquiera de los otros dos qubits, así que de hecho podemos detectar y
corregir hasta un error de inversión de fase usando este código. Pero desafortunadamente, como quizás ya habrás adivinado, ahora ya no podemos
corregir errores de inversión de bit. Sin embargo, no todo está perdido, porque de hecho podemos combinar estos dos códigos
para obtener un código que pueda corregir tanto errores de inversión de bit como de fase, y de hecho será capaz de
corregir cualquier error en un único qubit. Es el momento de hablar del código Shor de 9 qubits, que es un código cuántico
de corrección de errores que podemos obtener combinando los dos códigos que acabamos de ver, es decir, el código de
repetición de tres bits que nos permite corregir un único error de inversión de bit, y la versión modificada de ese código que nos permite corregir una única inversión de fase
Para ser más precisos, el código Shor de 9 qubits es el código que obtenemos concatenando los dos códigos, lo que significa
que primero aplicamos una codificación que codifica un qubit en tres, y luego aplicamos la otra codificación a cada uno de los
tres qubits por separado, así que obtendremos nueve qubits en total. Podemos expresar esto en forma de
un diagrama de circuit de la siguiente manera: primero aplicamos la versión modificada del código de repetición de 3 bits
que detecta errores de inversión de fase, y luego codificamos cada uno de los qubits resultantes de forma independiente usando el
código de repetición de 3 bits original. Así que si reducimos este circuit un poco para hacer algo de espacio, podemos
especificar el código en términos algo diferentes describiendo cómo los dos estados de la base estándar de nuestro qubit original se
codifican, y una vez que sabemos esto podemos determinar por linealidad cómo se codifica un vector de estado de qubit arbitrario
Ese es el código Shor de 9 qubits, y la idea es que uno de los códigos nos permite corregir errores de inversión de fase
y el otro código nos permite corregir errores de inversión de bit, y como veremos, eso implicará de hecho que podemos
corregir un error arbitrario en un único qubit. Ahora veamos cómo podemos detectar y corregir errores usando el código Shor de 9 qubits,
empezando por los errores de inversión de bit, que también se llaman errores X. Aquí está el circuit que realiza
la codificación, y para que sea más fácil hablar de ello, pensaremos en los nueve qubits que obtenemos de este código como
agrupados en tres bloques de tres qubits, donde cada bloque representa la codificación que obtenemos al aplicar el
segundo paso de codificación, que es el código de repetición de 3 bits ordinario, denominado código interno en
este contexto, mientras que el código externo es el código utilizado para el primer paso de codificación, que en este caso es la versión modificada
del código de repetición de tres bits que funciona para errores de inversión de fase. Para corregir errores de inversión de bit podemos
simplemente tratar cada uno de los bloques por separado: cada bloque es una codificación de un qubit usando el código de repetición de tres bits
y ese código protege contra errores de inversión de bit. Supongamos primero que ocurre un error X en cualquiera de los qubits,
como el qubit del medio en el bloque del medio. Si comprobamos independientemente cada uno de los bloques en busca de errores de inversión de bit y
corregimos cualquier error que encontremos, entonces este error será corregido y la codificación original será
recuperada. De hecho, podría haber incluso múltiples errores X y aun así corregirlos de esta manera, siempre que los errores estén
en bloques separados. Si tuviéramos dos o tres errores X en un solo bloque tendríamos un problema, pero
mientras haya como máximo un error X por bloque, el código interno los detectará y podremos recuperar el estado codificado original
Así que corregir errores de inversión de bit es bastante sencillo con este código. También necesitamos considerar los errores de inversión de fase
o, en otras palabras, los errores Z. Esta vez no está tan claro qué debemos hacer, porque el código externo es el que
corrige los errores de inversión de fase, pero no podemos detectarlos y corregirlos directamente porque el código interno de alguna manera
está en el camino. Pero veremos cómo hacer esto en breve. Para entender mejor cómo funcionan los errores X y Z
y los efectos que tienen dentro de los circuits cuánticos, es útil observar algunas relaciones simples entre estos errores y los gates C-NOT,
y esto también será útil en una lección posterior. Primero empecemos con los errores X
o gates X y cómo se relacionan con los gates C-NOT. Si aplicamos un gate X al
qubit objetivo de un C-NOT y luego aplicamos el C-NOT, eso es equivalente a intercambiar el orden y hacer el C-NOT
primero. Por otro lado, si aplicamos un gate X al qubit de control de un C-NOT y luego aplicamos el C-NOT, no podemos simplemente
cambiar el orden, sino que tenemos que aplicar el gate X a ambos qubits, y puedes comprobar todas estas relaciones por tu cuenta
si quieres, pensando en qué les sucede a los estados de la base estándar, por ejemplo. La situación es similar para los errores Z,
excepto que los roles de los qubits de control y objetivo se intercambian. En particular, si realizamos un
gate Z en el qubit de control de un C-NOT y luego realizamos el C-NOT, eso tiene el mismo efecto que realizar el
gate Z después del C-NOT. Pero si realizamos el gate Z en el qubit objetivo, entonces eso es
equivalente a primero realizar el C-NOT y luego aplicar un gate Z a ambos qubits. Y finalmente, todas estas
relaciones son simétricas en el sentido de que siempre podemos intercambiar el orden de los gates en ambos lados de cada ecuación,
lo que es equivalente a tomar la inversa o la transpuesta conjugada de ambos lados, dado que los gates X, Z y C-NOT
son todos sus propias inversas. Ahora consideremos los errores de inversión de fase y cómo podemos detectarlos y corregirlos
usando el código Shor de 9 qubits. Aquí está nuestro circuit de codificación y seguiremos pensando en los nueve
qubits usados en la codificación como agrupados en tres bloques de tres qubits. Supongamos que ocurre un error Z en
cualquiera de los qubits, como el indicado aquí. Usando lo que acabamos de observar sobre los gates Z
y los gates C-NOT, eso es equivalente a dos errores Z anteriores al C-NOT: uno en el
control y uno en el qubit objetivo, y estos errores resulta que conmutan con el otro gate del bloque, así que
podemos intercambiar el orden y esto es lo que obtenemos: el error Z inferior no hace nada porque actúa sobre un estado cero
y podemos deslizar todo lo demás y obtener este diagrama. Entonces lo que encontramos es que un error Z en algún lugar dentro
del bloque central es equivalente a un error Z que ocurre en el qubit central antes de la segunda fase de codificación, y
puedes razonar exactamente lo mismo para un error Z en cualquiera de los qubits: un phase flip en cualquier qubit dentro de un bloque
es equivalente a un phase flip en el qubit correspondiente antes de la codificación interna, y eso es bastante sencillo e intuitivo si
piensas en cómo los errores Z afectan al código de repetición de tres bits. Así que una opción para lidiar con un error Z
es decodificar el código interno y luego detectar y corregir errores Z usando el código externo, que es la versión modificada
del código de repetición de 3 bits que puede corregir un error Z. Eso corrige nuestro error Z, y
podríamos volver a codificar con el código interno si quisiéramos. También podemos corregir errores Z
en su lugar, por así decirlo, sin decodificar y volver a codificar, y es bastante sencillo, pero para explicar cómo
podemos hacerlo necesitaremos un poco más de espacio. Supón que decodificamos el código interno
y luego calculamos el síndrome para el código externo usando el mismo método de antes, donde solo involucramos los tres qubits del código externo, y
luego volvemos a codificar. Pues bien, podemos simplificar todos estos gates un poco, y de hecho
podemos usar las relaciones entre las NOT gates y las CNOT gates que observamos hace unos momentos para ayudar con esa
tarea, y al hacerlo podemos ahorrar cuatro gates. Este es el circuit que obtenemos. Si un error Z ha ocurrido en uno
de los qubits, lo que el síndrome nos indica ahora no es qué qubit experimentó un error Z, sino en qué bloque ocurrió el error Z,
pero eso no importa, porque sabemos que no importa qué qubit dentro de un bloque experimente un error Z: el
efecto es el mismo para los tres qubits dentro de ese bloque. Así que de hecho podemos corregir el error Z aplicando una Z gate a cualquiera de
los qubits dentro de ese bloque. Esto, por cierto, es un ejemplo de lo que se llama degeneración en un código
corrector de errores, donde no identificamos de forma única un error dado, pero somos capaces de corregirlo de todas formas. Por último, supongamos que tanto un
bit flip como un phase flip ocurren, posiblemente en el mismo qubit. Por ejemplo, supongamos que un
bit flip y un phase flip ocurren en este qubit de aquí. Resulta que estos errores pueden ser
detectados y corregidos de forma completamente independiente, y de hecho no importa si corregimos cada bloque por un
bit flip primero y luego corregimos los phase flips, o si lo hacemos al revés. Para ver esto, primero observemos
que el orden de estos errores no importa, así que podemos invertirlos si queremos. La razón no es porque
X y Z conmuten, porque no lo hacen: X * Z es igual a menos Z * X, pero el
factor menos uno no tiene efecto en esta situación porque es una fase global. Ahora podemos mover el error Z igual que
antes, y en este punto es evidente que si primero corrigiéramos cada bloque por errores X y luego corrigiéramos
los errores Z, habríamos corregido ambos errores. Alternativamente, si por alguna razón
decidiéramos corregir primero los errores Z, podríamos hacerlo, y el error X no tiene absolutamente ningún efecto en ese proceso.
Eso tiene que ser cierto porque, primero, el error X conmuta con cada gate del circuit que calcula el
síndrome del código externo, y segundo, el orden entre el error X y la Z gate que aplicamos para hacer la
corrección no importa, igual que argumentamos cuando la Z gate era un error. Eso permite la corrección del error Z,
y luego podemos corregir cada bloque para eliminar el error X. Entonces lo que hemos argumentado es que
podemos corregir un error X, un error Z, o ambos en cualquiera de los qubits usando este código.
De hecho, podemos corregir más errores que eso, como múltiples errores X siempre que caigan en bloques diferentes,
o múltiples errores Z siempre que a lo sumo un bloque reciba un número impar de ellos. Pero lo que será más relevante de aquí en adelante
es que podemos corregir un error X, un error Z o ambos en cualquier qubit. En la última parte de la lección
veremos cómo esto es de hecho suficiente para concluir que este código puede corregir un error arbitrario en cualquier
qubit. Antes de pasar a la última parte de la lección, en la que consideraremos errores cuánticos arbitrarios, veremos brevemente
el rendimiento del código de Shor de N qubits cuando los errores representados por matrices de Pauli ocurren aleatoriamente en los
qubits. Para ser más concretos, consideremos un modelo de ruido simple donde los errores ocurren de forma independiente en los qubits,
con cada qubit experimentando un error con probabilidad p y sin correlación entre errores en qubits diferentes.
El peor caso para el código de Shor de 9 qubits es que ocurra un error Y, es decir, tanto un error X como un error Z,
en cada qubit afectado, y asumiremos este peor caso solo para obtener una cota
del rendimiento del código. Pero también podrías considerar, por ejemplo, que los tres errores de Pauli son igualmente
probables. Ahora supón que Q es un qubit en algún estado particular que queremos proteger contra errores, e imagina que
tenemos la opción de usar el código de Shor de 9 qubits. ¿Deberíamos usarlo? La respuesta no es necesariamente
sí, porque si hay demasiado ruido, es decir, si p es demasiado grande, usar el código de Shor podría empeorar las cosas,
igual que ocurría con el código de repetición cuando p es mayor que 1/2. Pero si p es suficientemente pequeño, entonces la
respuesta es sí, deberíamos usar el código. Así que veamos por qué y qué significa que p sea demasiado grande o suficientemente pequeño.
Para este código, el código de Shor puede corregir cualquier error de Pauli en un solo qubit, y en el peor
caso, donde los errores de Pauli son errores Y, esto significa que el código protege Q exitosamente con una probabilidad dada por
la expresión que se muestra en pantalla. Concretamente, el código funciona cuando no hay errores, y eso ocurre
con probabilidad 1 menos p elevado a 9, porque hay nueve qubits que deben quedar cada uno sin verse afectados. Y funciona cuando hay
exactamente un error; considerando que hay nueve qubits distintos que podrían verse afectados, esto ocurre con probabilidad 9 * p * (1 - p) elevado a 8.
Por otro lado, si no usáramos el código, nuestro único qubit quedaría sin verse afectado por un error con
probabilidad 1 menos p. Así que el código solo ayuda cuando la primera probabilidad es mayor que la segunda.
Dado que estas expresiones representan nuestras probabilidades de éxito en los dos casos —cuando usamos el código y cuando
no lo usamos— aquí hay una gráfica de estas dos funciones para valores pequeños de p, y encontramos que el punto de equilibrio ocurre en
aproximadamente 3 y 3/4 por ciento. Así que si p es menor que este valor, el código
ayuda. En el punto de equilibrio las probabilidades son iguales, así que solo estamos desperdiciando nuestro tiempo junto con 8 qubits si
usamos el código, pero por lo demás no hay ningún problema. Y más allá de ese punto, definitivamente no deberíamos usar este código,
porque de hecho está aumentando la probabilidad de un error en el qubit codificado, al que normalmente nos referimos como el
qubit lógico en este contexto. Y eso ocurre simplemente porque la probabilidad de dos o más errores en nueve qubits es
mayor que la probabilidad de un error en un solo qubit para valores de p en ese rango. El 3 y 3/4% puede no parecer muy
bueno, sobre todo en comparación con el 50%, que es el punto de equilibrio análogo para el código de repetición de tres bits. Para
información clásica, pero es más difícil proteger la información cuántica y, además, aunque esto
código representa un descubrimiento brillante como el primer código de corrección de errores cuánticos, y resulta ser excelente para propósitos pedagógicos, el hecho de que
la realidad es que simplemente no es un código tan bueno en términos prácticos. Hasta ahora hemos considerado errores X
y errores Z en el contexto del código Shore de 9 qubit. Ahora consideremos errores arbitrarios
comenzando primero con errores unitarios. Por ejemplo, un error así podría corresponder a una rotación muy pequeña
de la esfera de Bloch, que posiblemente representa un error introducido por un gate que no es perfecto, por ejemplo
o podría ser cualquier otra operación unitaria sobre un qubit, y no necesariamente algo cercano a la identidad
operación. Podría parecer difícil corregir este tipo de errores, ya que hay infinitos errores posibles así
y es inconcebible que pudiéramos identificar exactamente cuál es el error y luego deshacerlo, pero
en realidad no necesitamos hacer nada distinto a lo que ya hemos discutido. Mientras podamos corregir un bit flip, un phase flip o ambos, entonces
de hecho lograremos corregir un error unitario arbitrario de un solo qubit, y ahora te explicaré por qué
es así. Primero, como todas las matrices 2x2, podemos expresar una matriz unitaria arbitraria
que representa un error sobre un solo qubit como una combinación lineal de las cuatro matrices de Pauli, incluyendo la identidad
matriz. Y, por cierto, como quizás hayas notado, uso X, Y y Z en mayúsculas para denotar las matrices de Pauli que no son la identidad
y seguiré haciéndolo durante el resto de esta serie. Es lo convencional en la corrección de errores cuánticos y también facilita
la lectura en este contexto. También será conveniente usar subíndices para indicar sobre cuál
qubit actúa una operación unitaria de qubit dada. Por ejemplo, si usamos la convención de numeración de qubit de Qiskit
comenzando desde el qubit cero a la derecha, entonces tenemos las expresiones que se muestran en la pantalla para
varias operaciones unitarias sobre qubits individuales, donde en cada caso tensorializamos la matriz unitaria con la matriz identidad
en todos los demás qubits. Entonces, en particular, podemos expresar UK, es decir, U aplicada al qubit K, como la misma
combinación lineal que antes, excepto que cada matriz de Pauli se aplica al qubit K. No necesitamos preocuparnos por el
subíndice para la identidad. Por cierto, aquí se entiende que esta es la identidad en todos los
qubits. Ahora supón que |ψ⟩ es la codificación de 9 qubit de un estado de qubit. Si el error U le ocurre al
qubit k, entonces obtenemos Uk * |ψ⟩, que podemos expresar como una combinación lineal de operaciones de Pauli actuando sobre |ψ⟩, lo cual es
simplemente |ψ⟩ en el caso de la identidad. En este punto, será útil observar que la matriz Y de Pauli
es igual a i * X * Z, así que podemos hacer esa sustitución en nuestra
expresión. Entonces este error ha ocurrido y ahora supón que intentamos corregirlo usando el mismo procedimiento que
antes. El primer paso es calcular el síndrome, que en el caso del código Shor tiene 8 bits de longitud: dos bits para cada una de las
tres veces que usamos el código interno, junto con dos bits adicionales para el código externo. Pero en realidad no importa, podemos simplemente pensarlo como
una cadena de longitud fija. Aquí hay una descripción del estado que obtenemos justo antes de la medición del síndrome, donde cada
síndrome son los ocho bits que obtenemos del error de Pauli correspondiente. Observa en este punto que los dos
sistemas están correlacionados en general, y realmente esta es la clave para que todo esto funcione. Al medir el síndrome,
lo que efectivamente haremos es colapsar el estado en uno donde una de las cuatro operaciones de Pauli ha sido aplicada al
qubit k de |ψ⟩, y sabremos por el síndrome qué operación de Pauli fue, así que podemos corregirla si
es necesario. En particular, si medimos el síndrome y realizamos la corrección apropiada, obtenemos un estado de la
forma que se muestra en la pantalla, que de manera crucial es un estado producto. Tenemos nuestra codificación original sin corromper como el
factor tensorial de la derecha, que es lo más importante aquí, y a la izquierda tenemos una matriz densidad σ que
describe un síndrome de error aleatorio, pero ya no hay ninguna correlación con el sistema que nos importa, que es
el de la derecha, porque los errores han sido corregidos. En este punto podemos descartar los qubits de síndrome o reiniciarlos
si queremos usarlos de nuevo, y eso en realidad es bastante importante, porque así es como la aleatoriedad o entropía
generada por los errores se elimina del sistema. Y así es como funciona la discretización de errores, al menos para los errores unitarios.
En esencia, al medir el síndrome, efectivamente proyectamos el error en un error descrito por
una matriz de Pauli. A primera vista, puede parecer demasiado bueno para ser verdad que podamos corregir errores unitarios arbitrarios
así, incluso errores que son pequeños y apenas perceptibles por sí solos. Pero lo importante que hay que entender aquí
es que este es un error unitario sobre un solo qubit y, por el diseño del código, una operación de un solo qubit no puede cambiar el
estado del qubit lógico que está siendo codificado. Todo lo que puede hacer es sacar el estado del espacio de las codificaciones válidas,
pero las correcciones lo devuelven justo a donde estaba. Finalmente, consideremos qué ocurre
cuando ocurre un error arbitrario, no necesariamente unitario. La configuración es la misma que antes:
hemos codificado un qubit en 9 usando el código Shor y algún error arbitrario representado por un canal de qubit φ
ocurre en uno de los qubits. Como veremos, todo va a funcionar de manera bastante similar
a como lo hizo con los errores unitarios, y el primer paso para verificar esto es considerar una representación de Kraus de nuestro
error. Lo que podemos hacer ahora es seguir exactamente el mismo razonamiento que con los errores unitarios, excepto que aplicamos ese
razonamiento a las matrices de Kraus en lugar de a una sola matriz unitaria que representa un error.
En particular, cada matriz de Kraus puede expresarse como una combinación lineal de matrices de Pauli, y esto nos permite
expresar la acción de este error φ sobre cualquier qubit K en la forma que se muestra aquí en la
pantalla. Todo lo que hacemos realmente es expandir las matrices de Kraus como combinaciones lineales de matrices de Pauli.
Si luego calculamos y medimos el síndrome de error y corregimos los errores que se revelen, obtendremos un
estado similar al que teníamos en el caso de un error unitario. No voy a detallar todo, es bastante similar al caso unitario
y también un poco más complicado de escribir, pero conceptualmente es bastante
sencillo. Debo mencionar que todo esto se generaliza a otros códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos, incluyendo códigos que pueden corregir errores en múltiples
qubits. En ese caso, los errores en múltiples qubits pueden expresarse como combinaciones lineales de productos tensoriales de matrices de Pauli
y, correspondientemente, los diferentes síndromes posibles describirán correcciones que se realizan en múltiples qubits en lugar de solo uno.
qubit, pero la idea subyacente es exactamente la misma. De nuevo, midiendo el síndrome
efectivamente proyectamos o colapsamos los errores en un conjunto discreto de posibilidades representadas por productos tensoriales
de matrices de Pauli, y al corregir esos errores, es decir, los errores de Pauli, podemos recuperar el estado
codificado original. Mientras tanto, cualquier aleatoriedad generada en el proceso se transfiere a los qubits de síndrome, que luego podemos
descartar o reiniciar, lo cual es crucial porque así es como se elimina del sistema la entropía generada por los errores y las mediciones de síndrome.
Y eso es el final de la lección en la que hemos dado un primer vistazo a la
corrección de errores cuánticos, incluyendo el código Shore de 9 qubit y la discretización de errores. Espero que te unas a mí en la
siguiente lección, en la que discutiremos el formalismo estabilizador, que nos proporciona una herramienta poderosa para describir y
analizar una clase amplia e interesante de códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos, incluyendo los que son candidatos prometedores para
computadoras cuánticas reales. Hasta entonces, ¡adiós!